hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my youtube viewers Wally who
is asking how do I stay so productive
and what is a typical day in my life
look like so Wally thanks for the
question this is something that I spent
a lot of time thinking about and I used
to be a crazy workaholic working you
know all hours of the day and as soon as
I got married and had a kid life starts
to change and you want to be able to
spend more time at home and spend more
time with your family so right now my
main schedule I try to work from monday
to thursday so most of my work is done
from monday to thursday and then from
one o'clock in the afternoon to six
o'clock at night so i'll work five hours
a day four days a week for the most part
and when i'm doing this what i try to do
is create one and a half hour chunks of
time and so what i mean by this is every
day I'll / day into three main chunks
with 15 minute breaks in between so one
that one might be email one might be
working on projects and I'll go through
a couple later on in the video but I
find I'm most productive when I can work
in a 90-minute chunk and get as much
done as i can in at 90 minutes and then
take a complete break 15 minutes go
outside check the mail breathe in some
fresh air relax clear my head come back
and do something completely different so
lonely check email once a day I don't
answer the phone unless it's scheduled
calls most people don't even have my
phone number but those who do I don't
even answer it unless it's a scheduled
call so I try to keep my day free from
as much attractions as possible so the
nutters in the phone is one big thing
the other is no email so I'll only do
email once a day and every day I have a
chunk of time and now and a half that I
spend on email and make sure that I can
spend the rest of my time being super
productive so if you only work in five
hours a day you don't have a lot of time
to get a lot of stuff done so you have
to be super productive in that time that
you do spend so my email is an hour and
a half of that and if i don't answer
everybody within that hour and a half
then it goes to the next day's email so
i find that to be super helpful for me I
used to be an email freak and answering
all the time and I found that it
prevented me from be able to do some
real work so typically how my week will
work right now I guess on Monday again
I'll get in the office of one and I'll
usually check email and then in the
afternoon I'll have two chunks of time
so you know just say chunk and chunk
what I'll do here is a task for the week
so this could be writing a no blog post
doing my facebook stuff for the week
i'll try to schedule as much stuff as
possible in advance so like facebook
posts i might plan out the entire week
on monday so that it's all ready set to
go my youtube videos i'll have already
them they'll be all edited and then I'll
on Monday I'll set them up for the whole
week to go out so as much as possible if
you find yourself doing repetitive tasks
you either want to chunk them up
together so you're more productive doing
those tasks you do them all at once and
then schedule them out or also look for
ways to automate things delegate things
or maybe even eliminate things so as
I've grown my business we brought on a
team of people who helped me with a
whole bunch of different things in my
business so this could be different task
and then I also leave some time for what
I call CEO time and these are important
tasks that I used to grow my business
that is not working on my business in my
business but more working on my business
so it could be hiring new staff working
on a new project testing out something
new that I want to work on for the
website or my business things that are
will grow the business that are kind of
admin keep me tied into the kind of day
to day with my company so that's monday
monday is always a super busy day I
don't schedule any calls or anything
else on Monday because I'm so busy
creating everything that
to do basically for the entire week
anything that has to get done for the
week basically gets done on monday and
then i'm done so that's Monday on
Tuesday I'll also get in at one o'clock
and I'll check my email and then that's
it for the day the rest of the day I
still have my two other chunks and both
of these are just CEO times and this
just gives me a chance to work on big
projects that sometimes take a lot of
time so if I'm writing you know a book
for example or creating new content that
I want to expand my business so i need
to do interviews something that is
really going to help grow my business
that'll be here so i found that having
an entire day to be able to focus on
that really helps so i'll be done my
email at two-thirty and then have a hat
15 minute break and then to forty five
to six o'clock with a little break in
between the basin working on all CEO
business growth stuff and you'll find
that your growth can really take off the
more you're working on your business
versus in so setting up system setting
up processes hiring new people other
plans that i have to grow my business
testing things out that's all part of my
CEO time so tuesdays are a lot of fun
I've gotten all my work for the week out
of the way on monday and i still have my
email to the handle on tuesday i still
check the once a day but then i have the
rest of it to be able to do stuff to
grow my business wednesday is a touch
different wednesday i'll usually get in
at 10 and i'll start doing my videos so
these videos it's a wednesday morning
i'm doing the videos i used to do them
at one o'clock but i found that the
light wasn't enough coming and i got big
windows here at my office but I get more
morning sunshine than afternoon sunshine
so I found the video quality was better
when I was filming in the morning so
I'll come in and start doing my videos
right away and then
after I'll take a break so do that do a
break and I'll go with my wife and we
usually go to Starbucks and chapters the
chapters is a bookstore here so like
barnes and nobles and we'll just relax
and plan our lives when my son is at
school might read things that we want to
read or talk about what we want to work
on it's just kind of relaxed time for
the two of us and then I'll get back in
the afternoon afternoon and here all you
should do more videos but these will be
the tutorial type so sometimes people
ask me to do videos and I'll explain it
using my computer instead of be actually
on camera or I'll walk through tutorials
of how I use certain software tools I
think might help you guys as
entrepreneurs so I'll be afternoon and
then I'll also do another chunk of email
so I still have the three chunks one is
the 10 minutes sorry the ten o'clock
video the afternoon videos and the
emails so again I try to keep everything
the three main chunks of work every day
and then that kind of keeps paying vigor
a Turkey's been going gives me some
breaks in between and every day has its
own day that I new tasks that I have
each day and it kind of keeps me excited
to keep going so once it's a lot of fun
I know after hour you know I have my
email still every day but the rest of
the day is all fun stuff answering
questions like yours and doing other
video tutorials so when's there's a lot
of fun and then on Thursday Thursday
would be my meeting day and then a
little bit more CEO time so thursday
again I'll cut back to the one o'clock
I'll come in i'll do email and then for
the two chunks I'll do meetings and
either more meetings or CEO time again
so I booked all my meetings on thursdays
thursdays after I've done my email and
I'll either do a phone calls will do
kind of schedule them all back to back
or if somebody's coming to meet me we'll
meet at the starbucks in my building i
have a starbucks on the ground floor and
i'll come and have meetings there and
we'll be back to back to back so
everybody gets up to an hour of time
and that's that's what will happen so
we'll meet I'll have a meeting have
another meeting have another meeting or
do phone calls in between so I booked
everything for Thursday it just kind of
gets me in the space of of meeting
people and I find is less mental
shifting so it's easier to get stuff
done where if I had a meeting on Tuesday
and I'm meeting Wednesday a meeting
Thursday then every time I got to think
okay what am I going to do with this
meeting what are we talking about just
getting the minds of getting ready to
meet people instead of working on
projects and I find if I can chunk all
that into one day it makes it a lot
easier for me to kind of get it all done
and do it all at once so depending on
how many meetings or phone calls I have
the second chunk might be CEO time again
to work on projects or could just be
meetings when I finish the day on
Thursday I usually put an autoresponder
on my email saying that I'm away until
Monday afternoon we'll all get back to
them whoever emails me so that's my
typical day my typical week I guess in
the life of my monday the thursday
sometimes I you know I still experiment
with this with this plan I would usually
much rather do mornings than then
afternoons but because of my family
situation my wife teaches salsa so she's
always available in the mornings instead
of at night where she's teaching at
night and my son goes to school in the
afternoon and right now he's available
in the morning so we have mornings
together so we try to keep to that but
in general what I would love to do is
have my mornings will work on big
projects and then check email in the
afternoon the one time will kind of get
an exception to this is if I'm really
working on something to find a lot of
momentum then I want to keep it going so
you don't want to kill your project just
because you're one and a half hours is
up if you find that you're really
getting a lot of good momentum from it
and you're really in the flow so you
find you're gonna say to flow you're
making a lot of good progress I'll just
keep blasting through it it doesn't
happen that often though and you don't
want to fool yourself right you want to
say oh it's 230 in my one and a half
hours of emails up but I'm really
feeling the email this is awesome right
you don't want to make an excuse and you
know keep going on the email instead of
doing the more important stuff for your
business so it doesn't happen that often
but when it does you try to you
work with the momentum that you have so
that's pretty much it you know I'll
still do some reading of material blogs
that I like on the weekend and on Friday
but for the most part all my work gets
done monday to thursday 126 and that's
right now how I structure it up so while
I hope that helps if you guys liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below
helps me know you like them and we'll
make more just like it and if you have
some comments I'd love to hear them
below I'd love to hear how your schedule
looks and if you have any suggestions as
well please leave it in comments below
so thank you for watching and stay tuned
flex episode
you
you